[Music]
hey guys
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing hogwarts potions professor
and later head master severus snape and
his most powerful spells
and abilities now one thing that i want
to mention
right out of the gate is that snape is
one of the most powerful wizards in the
wizarding world
and what was most impressive about him
is that he wasn't even that old when he
died snape died at the tender age of 38
and though he wasn't quite at the level
of voldemort or
dumbledore he was getting there and had
he been around for a few decades longer
i think that snape may just have had a
shot at being the most powerful wizard
ever unfortunately we'll never know and
though i'm sure he had the potential to
achieve
insurmountable levels of power
realistically he did ultimately fall
short
of besting the likes of voldemort and
dumbledore with all
that being said however snape was still
amazing
and i feel like sometimes he's a little
underrated throughout the series
time and time again snape showcases
spells and abilities that are difficult
to conjure
and often unique he's also a
well-rounded wizard
because he was never afraid of venturing
into experimentation with the dark arts
he knows the good spells and the more
sinister spells
he knows it all snape is a testament to
what can be achieved if you're really
dedicated to something
as a student snape always had his head
in the books continually learning and
progressing
he was focused and he didn't let
temporary satisfaction
get in the way of achieving more
learning more
though he had a segue down a dark path
the result of bullying and the loss of
his friendship with lily
snape only used his hatred for the
marauders as fuel
it gave him the drive and the motivation
to be more
to do more in this video we're going to
be diving in
and looking at snape's five most
powerful spells and abilities
let's get started number five sektum
sempra
coming in at number five on the list is
snape's very own spell
sektum sempra we first see sektim's
emperor in the films
when harry uses it on malfoy in the
half-blood prince
sektum's emperor is a vicious dark curse
that acts like an invisible sword
causing lacerations hemorrhaging and
cuts upon its target
often after being struck the target will
lay their motionless
as they lose blood it is somewhat of a
specialty of snapes
and is featured in his textbook for
advanced potion making
the only treatment for sectim's emperor
is vulnera zenentor which was also
invented
by snape what's so dangerous about
sektim's emperor is that it was
seemingly easy for harry to cast
but still nearly killed draco malfoy the
first time that he used it
while the unforgivable curses require
intent and an understanding of the
spells
to effectively cast them sektum sempre
seemingly doesn't require this same
level of intent
or deep understanding but still produces
the same
lethal results i think that the only
thing that sets snape spell
apart from the traditional unforgivable
curses
crucio avada cadaver imperial is that it
has a counter charm
number four creating potions coming in
at number four on the list is snape's
mastery of potion making
snape held the position of potion's
master at hogwarts
from 1981 to 1996 proving himself to be
extremely adept
at the act of making potions snape
having always been studious and
committed to expanding his mind
was very successful at creating any sort
of potion that he desired
and thoroughly impressed his former
potions professor horace slughorn
in his school boy days in fact he was so
adept
and in such a leak of his own snape
basically rewrote a lot of the
instructions in his potion sex book
the same textbook that harry later
requires when harry potter first attends
psycholon's class
he hits the jackpot and finds the former
textbook of snape
the half-blood prince at first this was
just a regular textbook to harry
but as he began to flip through it he
noticed a few peculiarities
the first thing being the inscription by
its former owner
this book is the property of the half
blood prince
the next thing that he notices is that
on each page portions of the
instructions are scribbled out
and instead this half blood prince
character
had written in his own instructions
instructions that differed
from what the original recipe called for
and what harry quickly realized was that
these alternative instructions
were far better than the original
instructions as he was able to
effortlessly produce the potions that
cyclone called for in each of his
lessons
the book was like having cheat codes to
all of the potions lessons
and by following the instructions in the
book harry was able to
thoroughly impress slughorn this is a
massive testament to snape's prowess in
potions
hogwarts had been around for over a
thousand years and the potions textbooks
were written by
skilled potioneers but snape still had
managed to improve them
for the rest of the year harry continued
to follow the half-blood prince's
instructions
wherever they deviated from the original
author labatius borage
and it resulted in slughorn raving about
his abilities
there are many potions in harry potter
and i wouldn't put it past snape
to create any one of them powerful
potions include veritas serum which is
essentially a truth potion
felix felicis or liquid luck which
grants unusually good luck
amortentia which gives the drinker a
powerful obsession or infatuation with
the giver of the potion
and polyjuice potion which allows the
drinker to assume the appearance of
someone else
snape could do them all number three
unsupported flight
coming in at number three is of course
or the ability to fly the only other
known witch or wizard
known to fly without a charm of some
sort is a dark lord himself
voldemort this achievement is extremely
uncommon
and is the sign of a truly powerful
witch or wizard
jk rowling is reported to have stated
that all wizards have the power of
flight
innately but the vast vast majority need
a broom to achieve it
in the case of snape and voldemort they
are just so focused and powerful
they're able to channel the power to fly
and supported harnessing the energy
through themselves
rather than the broom flying can come in
handy in many different circumstances
allowing you to get away quickly or
pursue a target with ease
unsupported flight should not be
confused with levitation
which doesn't work on humans and only
allows objects to fly a few feet above
the ground
number two spell creation coming in at
number two is spell creation
spell creation can be highly dangerous
and has proven historically
to be extremely difficult only witches
and wizards with extreme patience
and an astounding understanding of magic
have been able to successfully invent
new spells snape who exhibits both of
these things
has proven himself to be quite
successful at smell creation
having created a multitude of spells
over the years
this list includes the toenail growing
hex which causes the victim's toenails
to grow alarmingly
fast langlock which affixes the victim's
tongue to the roof of their mouth
the mafiato charm which fills the ears
of anyone nearby with an unidentifiable
buzzing
leather corpus which lifts the victim's
body into the air
liberal corpus which drops them out of
the air vulnera senantor which heals
wounds inflicted by septum's emperor
and lastly and perhaps most importantly
sectim's emperor which i mentioned
earlier
a few other witches and wizards that
we're introduced to have also created
spells
but of all of them snape appears to have
the most impressive portfolio
and i think that this is truly
indicative of his magical ability
i can't even begin to imagine what sorts
of spells
snape would have come up with had he
lived a longer fuller life
number one occlumency occlumency is the
practice of magically closing one's mind
against legitimacy which involves
navigating through people's minds
to access the thoughts and feelings
sometimes even
influencing them severus snape is a
master occlumens
and is perhaps one of the only people
besides dumbledore whose mind is safe
from a master legitimates like voldemort
snape acts as a double agent in the
films
but is still able to deceive lord
voldemort despite
frequent interaction and i think this
truly speaks to his ability
as an occlums perhaps even surpassing
dumbledore's abilities in the subject
a basic level oklahomans is simply able
to clear their mind
in the event of a mind infiltration
while a master occlumens
is able to change their thought patterns
in order to further confuse
the legitimates given that occlumency is
a rare skill
and its snape is so adept at it i
thought that it was fitting that it be
placed at the top of this list
and that concludes the list i really
wish snape had lived longer
full of life so that we could have seen
the boundaries of magic
being pushed even further however in the
time that he was around
he contributed a lot what do you guys
think
do you agree with this list let me know
down in the comment section
below until next time you're a wizard
[Music]
howdy
you